[Music]
oh there we go
okay so we're gonna play e4 um
and we are going to play well what
should we play uh we can play our ry
lopez
let's play ry lopez let's play our lopez
which is my main opening bishop a4 this
is main line theory
okay so b5 is already a mistake uh well
not really a mistake there is a line
called the norwegian variation where
black actually does this
now the reason this is inaccurate is
because this bishop
kind of belongs on b3 right you're
sending the bishop to a square
where it wants to go anyway and here the
problem is
black is not developed enough right
black doesn't have his bishop developed
so logically speaking
what do we want to do when our opponent
isn't developed enough
what act do what action do we want to
take
and how do we take this action in the
fastest possible way open up the center
shred it apart
now knight g5 isn't that good because of
d5
but we want to go d4 shred the center
logical logical d4 now knight g5 is kind
of like the fried liver but it's not an
improved version for
for for white i'll talk about this after
the game
but after d5 black is completely fine
it's it's kind of like the fried liver
with some minor changes which are not
necessarily in white's favor so
i wouldn't rush to play knight g5 there
as tempting as it is
and i'll write this down to explain it
okay
but now the situation changes
these moves create sort of tension in
the center
and what that means is now
what move becomes quite a bit stronger
so nitrogen five now it's very
interesting but then maybe still d5
okay so we need to sort through the
observations here right
um the most obvious and most tempting
move is d takes e5
that's not actually a very good move
that takes e5
simplifies the position and if you guys
calculate that variation it leads to a
queen trade the problem is
we don't want a queen trade we want more
than just taking queen
so let me think about this for a second
actually if you don't mind
i'm actually doing some calculation
myself
okay so the sort of developmental
approach is to play bishop g5
but that's a little bit too slow it
allows white black to develop but here's
the thing guys
what move do we need to revisit what
move do we need to revisit
now that d46 has been played the
situation has changed
well bishop f7 is the right idea but it
but this is premature now we go knight
g5 because
here's the thing use the method of
comparison
we're still attacking f7 so like knight
takes d4 here allows a fork
so black's only real way of defending
this pawn like literally
bishop e6 would blunder upon is to play
d5
but now that we've created this tension
in the center
the move d5 basically plunges black
head first into this crazy position
where
we are a lot closer to castling than
black is remember that our ultimate goal
here is to open up the center and so we
are essentially
forcing black into doing it and we are
positioning the knight on a really
really good square
where it could potentially sacrifice
itself on f7 so in a certain sense the
addition of the move d4
is what we have here if we go knight g5
immediately black plays d5
here we have played d4 and we get the
same position with the inclusion of that
move
obviously it's good for white we open up
the center and the bishop is now
tying itself to the knight which means
there's no like discovered attack ideas
if that makes
sense so this is something people don't
do enough of right
a certain move doesn't work or it's not
that effective and then people forget
about that move they just bury it right
it's never gonna work
but if you keep revisiting it you might
find that the circumstances have changed
that's a really interesting move by alex
bishop g4
now his idea is that if we cover the
attack on the queen with f3
the bishop is going to drop back to h5
that's actually a very ingenious idea
and the bishop is going to defend the
pawn
now if we play knight takes f7 that
leads to a queen trade
also not very desirable but what can we
do like what is the intermediate kind of
move here
we don't have to play knight takes f7
right we don't have to get obsessed with
forking him
we can play bishop takes f7 which is the
next best thing we take his pawn free
pawn
and we drive his king out into the
center that's not too bad right and then
we'll play f3 right
then we'll play f3 defending the queen
with tempo forcing the bishop out of
there
now black is not completely lost here
because what we need to notice here okay
so bishop h5 isn't actually a great move
this helps us do our job and i'll
explain that in great in greater detail
after the game
so the thing is this bishop on f7 was
kind of stranded
so by leaving it there black would have
gained a tempo now we get a chance to
take the bishop
and now we have all of the good stuff
remaining okay
so normally in such positions normally
we don't want to close down the center
but there is an extenuating factor here
and that factor is the e6 square
what do we want to put there and how do
we make that happen
how do we make that happen we want a
knight there so we do play d5
now there's a couple of things to
understand here we do close down the
center from a purely logical standpoint
closing down the center is not good here
because his king is weak so we want to
keep the center open but we're going to
reopen the center
how are we going to reopen the center
once we establish a knight on e6 and
that's why we're doing this that e6
square is like freaking black caviar
that's an amazing square
bingo we're going to play f4 right so in
chess
this is what flexibility really means
we're closing down the center yes bad
yes from a logical standpoint but we're
doing it for a very specific reason we
want to get the knight to b6 and we're
doing it with the knowledge that later
we're going to reopen the center with
that form we're going to do it with even
greater effect because we're going to
open up that f file
that f file is going to be the most
direct avenue to his game
so we can actually play f4 immediately
here
and there's no need to wait but if we
wanted to prepare f4 what would be the
best way of preparing for yeah we can
castle so castling is the more
methodical approach we make our king
safe
and now f4 is stronger because we
anticipate the f-file opening
which means we preemptively put the rook
on f1 and while we're at it we make the
king safer
do we need to do anything with this like
is there any need to not play f4 here
because he's played c6
no that's the power of a pawn chain
right this pawn on e4
is protecting its neighbor on d5 so c
takes d5 is not a threat here in fact it
helps us
because it opens up the e file so we go
f4
yeah knight takes h7 and bishop g5 he
had knight covers
uh the diagonal with knight f6 i thought
about that
yeah so bishop g5 is fine but bishop g5
would be met with knight f6 and the
funny thing is we use this knight to our
advantage
because we're attacking with our queen
and if knight takes f4
no problem then bishop takes f4 and rook
takes f4 and we've basically removed the
defender then i can
act act as a defender here so if i were
alex i would go knight f6 like i would
at least try to beef up the security
along the ufo that's not going to help
him
okay so what should we do now should we
take the knight should we do something
else we have several ways to win the
game we have like a
a very business-like approach or we can
basically go for checkmate
so it's not a free night if we if we
take the knight then he takes our knight
so like logically speaking we can play e
takes d5 that's the simplest move that's
the move we're gonna make but
actually that's not the move we're gonna
make there is an even better move
which just wins a piece right we're
attacking his knight he's attacking our
knight
so logically we should be thinking okay
can we move our knight
with a threat yeah we can we can take
the bishop
and we threaten the queen but that's not
the important part and we take on h5 so
we've traded
in one advantage for another advantage
but the thing is like none of our other
advantages have gone anywhere the king
is still exposed
uh the f-file is still about to get
opened so now we're up a piece and we're
attacking this is absolutely crushing
now why did i choose that because in a
certain sense it's like life insurance
right now
we're attacking and we're not taking any
risks because god forbid the attack
fails hey we're still up a piece
but we need to complete our development
let's not forget about that we need to
complete our development asap
this knight can now head to d5 which is
a beautiful central outpost
and then we can get the bishop out to e3
we can bring the cavalry in
if necessary to d1 let's give him a
check on d5
now knight to b6 may seem like a fork
but it's a little bit premature for what
reason
if we go knight b6 here what defensive
move does he have that's why we're gonna
get our bishop out first
because he has queen to a7 pinning the
knight against the king so let's go
bishop e3 to cover that diagonal
the additional thing is we've already
won a piece
we don't really need to hunt down for
exchanges here now we can focus on
giving checkmate if that makes sense
like you need to make those judgment
calls in the game okay i've won a piece
uh now i don't need to even give up my
beautiful night for that exchange even
if that does win
an exchange uh because we're going for
the greater glory here of
of just crushing him and now we want to
play f takes c5
and once we get the f file rook fade is
going to be an absolutely devastating
threat
our rooks are connected while his art
that's the key thing
in fact we don't even have to do
anything we can play f65 here
but no need for fanciness instead where
can we go with the queen
like how do we play with tempo
how do we play with tempo so we get we
have two possible moves we can go up to
h6
but uh we can also give a check on on g5
or h4 doesn't matter we'll go
queen g5 check and uh if he goes king c8
then obviously we have
a fork on b6 we we shouldn't forget
about that
if he goes to e8 then we do open up that
that f
file and we stream in with a rook and we
give checkmate
okay so knight e7 doesn't change
anything because this knight is pinned
we can also give a devastating check on
b6 but again
the less you know craziness the better
we just play f65
and check and now he has to cover with
this queen queen takes e7 is basically
made
and the game is over queen takes c7 is
the fastest queen is pinned
right king can't take the queen because
knight defends it king has to move aside
and we take the queen with checkmate
that was a
really really good game lots of
instructive stuff there and
if alex wants to hop on a discord call
i'm totally down but
i realize it's pretty late so he might
be uh
he might be pretty tired and just wants
to listen so oh yeah perfect alex that
that would be awesome so um
let me add you on discord one second
could you maybe dm me on twitch your
your discord uh handle and i'll add you
alex
let me go full cam
is cool because i want to know your
thoughts i'm gonna i'm gonna torture the
hell out of you
you're gonna see how annoying i am
and i'm gonna invite invite them to an
analysis board
all right it's one second
oh you messaged me on discord okay okay
perfect
let me see oh gotcha okay
hello hey alex it's a personal pleasure
to meet you it's going well how are you
no that was actually a lot of stuff let
me just uh let me set your output so so
my
chat can hear you okay guys now can you
say something alex
i thought i should have played d5 gosh
dang it
um oh hey yeah okay now i think that was
the move
i wanted to play d5 and then i thought
i'd get
cute with this weird little bishop move
around tactic but then you did get cute
that was actually really ingenious idea
uh yeah you guys can hear him now let me
invite you to an analysis board
um and your alex um you should get an
invite pop-up right also thanks for
hopping on the call so fast i know it's
really late and stuff for sure
okay i'll let me know if you got that
invite uh oh i have to go to my live
just to see yeah live chess let me let
me send another one in
okay i send another one sorry yup
just did
i don't like it if you're on the yeah
you're in live chess
yeah i think so i haven't gotten any
invites or anything
oh let me try and invite selected
okay let me cancel it and then reinvite
you
sorry this crashes sometimes okay i
tried again
no nothing coming up
no it's really weird uh
just like restart uh can you like maybe
refresh uh
your live trust and then if not like
i'll just like we'll open our own
instances of the game and then i'll just
like
walk you through whoa knock out with 10
gifts and thanks man
yeah try to refresh it not not a problem
yeah i've refreshed it all right i
invited you again
all right chess.com is getting a message
from me after this no problem
so let's just uh i'll just basically if
you can open the game
on your own screen yeah i'll uh i'll
basically go by move number and you guys
on my chat thank you knockout for the 10
gifted appreciate it
uh so basically ry lopez right which
you just said you love yeah so much
now move four b5 is actually a bit of a
mistake interesting i thought it was
just a theory
like move so it's called the norwegian
variation like it does have a name
and it is a move that you will often
want to play at some point the problem
with playing it immediately
is once my bishop gets to b3 i'm
targeting the f7 pawn
and the reason that is dangerous is
because your king side isn't developed
yet so what you should do instead of b5
on move four is just go knight to f6
right the berlin so i would that's
actually not after a6 though move
move four sorry it interrupted move
forward after a6
okay uh the berlin is to play it
immediately immediately
gotcha so i actually would usually play
it i would see if they wanted to trade
their bishop
on c6 or not if they pushed it back then
i would bring my knight out but the
problem was
after that i would be playing d6 and
then they would just
or i would play like d5 or whatever it
was
they would just take my pawn on e5
and then i like never knew how to defend
that
or if they did trade if they trade or if
they don't trade once this pawn move
they just take it because they've got
this pin on my knight
and then i'm always like crap
that makes perfect sense so uh the thing
is like
after move four knight f6 right they
usually castle like move five capsules
right
so the thing is like you don't want to
push your d-pawn out just yet what you
want to focus on here is finishing your
king's side development so you actually
want to go bishop e7
move five easy
okay yeah so you're developing modestly
but
uh it's like top priority to finish your
kingside developer precisely so that you
can push the d-pawn out and
not have to deal with that [ __ ] with
with knight 65.
so bishop e7 usually white goes rookie
one move six
and only now when you're ready to castle
you play your favorite move b5 move six
got it and then i can castle i don't
have to worry about this stupid trap
bingo or you can play d6 first move
seven so bishop b3 d6 then you castle
and that actually leads to like then you
have a bunch of ways to set your pieces
up but basically you're out of the woods
like opening wise
if that makes sense that's so much nicer
and do you know what to do
if they take your knight on move four
the exchange variation and then they
take your pawn on e5
first of all do you know what to take
the bishop with i always take with the
d-pawn correct
correct because you want to open up your
bishop and then if they take knight
takes e5
what do you do i i
leave the game or something you're like
yeah
whoa another knockout no i think i i go
queen g5 and then i'm threatening
taking the pawn and the knight that is a
very good move actually that's the
second best move and knockout really
appreciated another bomb
but queen to d4 is even stronger that
gives black a small advantage
so i i used to play queen to d4
but then they just i i didn't know how
to i guess i i'm threatening the pawn
and the knight right
here thank you so much amazing take the
pun and then they
trade their queens or something i don't
know that's exactly what that means
that's literally what happened but but
the reason the black is better at the
end
knight f3 take queen takes e4 queen e2
then you trade queens right
so move eight king takes e2 and you go
you develop your knight to knight f6
now white's king is out in the center
it's kind of a sitting duck
what people often don't understand is
even though the queens have been traded
that doesn't mean you can't attack him
in fact
you'll eventually put a rook on the e
file and that white
king is going to be in big big trouble
it's just a very nasty position for
white
okay so you're going to develop your
bishop you're going to castle long
and you're going to quickly slam a rook
onto the e-file that's just going to be
a bad position
so does that make sense yeah no that
makes plenty of sense
yeah dr why can't rookie one king of one
but but white can try to equalize but
it's just nasty so anyways going back to
the game
so uh i have one more question on this
line as many as
prior yes prior to them okay so
let's go back one and have them take and
on my my c
night and then i take with the d pawn
there's always like they make like one
move prior to this
that like screws everything up they'll
do some move like the light castle right
now
no castle that's the main move yeah so
castle
there's many variations i make now to
keep this pawn
alive and not because then i can't do my
like tricky stuff and i always lose that
pawn because i always
make the wrong move here right so
there's one line that's the trap line
and then the line that i play now i play
the move f6
literally defending the pawn like you
ain't taking [ __ ]
but the trap line is it's called the
fishing hook trap is to play bishop g4
move
five i don't know if you've seen this
trap that i'm about to show you uh-huh
so you pin the knight right
fair enough you're definitely going to
play one of them uh
and i'm going to be watching it but so
bishop g4 right
white can't take the pawn because he
spent so what white does usually is he
goes h3
and he tries to unpin the knight
so after h3 h5 well why
tell me why that's bad if you go bishop
h5 why can forcibly unpin the knight and
then win your pawn how can you do that
oh yeah i guess he would just push again
to g4 and then he would take the pawn
exactly what happened because i think i
have played this a couple times and they
just
push it back twice and then they take it
so i guess i'm
forced to probably yeah and then i get
this whole
stupid thing where i'm pinned full yeah
it just turns into a disgusting scenario
right but here's the mind-blowing thing
on move six you can play
onto h5 okay
and i remember learning about this the
first time 2005. there was a grand
master who showed me this and i was like
well
what i just take the bishop but do you
see the idea if you take the bishop you
take
on hg4 black is winning and now his
knight has to move
but he can't because then you've got
this mating line coming and so it's just
this
disgusting yeah completely disgusting
queen h4
and the one key important thing if white
tries to move his f pawn out after queen
h4 you're probably seeing this on my
stream
what is the key move here to stop the
king from escaping before delivering the
checkmate on http
bingo that's it that's how quickly the
game can end this is like a really
famous trap but it makes this line work
right so a lot of people don't know what
to do against h5
um normally like white's main line is to
play d3 just pawn to d3 and just
ignore the bishop and
then and i'll just give you like one
more move black doesn't need to move the
bishop yet because taking it is still
not being threatened how can black apply
pressure
on the f3 knight after move seven d3
uh i guess i can move my queen out to f6
but you do i realize it looks artificial
but that's actually the theoretical move
looks it works hard officially yeah
because i mean at worst case they're you
know you're going to open up their
i mean no matter what you're going to
open them up so right
right exactly exactly and that's the
theory like white moves his bishop out
to e3 then you play bishop takes f3
but because you're opening up the king's
side white needs to take with the queen
you get this
end game and black is completely fine
here that's one of the reasons the
exchange variation is innocuous
holy [ __ ] radcliff another 10. thank you
so much man
yeah sorry my chat's popping off another
10 from radcliffe appreciate it
radcliffe popping off go off man
crazy and just exchanging 10 gifted so
does this make sense that is
that is one of the main lines the other
is to play move five f6 we don't have to
go over that right now
i would recommend bishop g4 for you okay
so that's the exchange variation any
other questions like regarding the
theory before we like talk about
the the great stuff that happened in the
game in the game
no i mean i hate this line but i feel a
little more comfortable now because
those are two of the ways that i get
like
brutalized in it because i've lost to
the thing that you've done
multiple times um and
in different ways i feel like but it
still always ends up in the same way
where like
i spend time developing the wrong stuff
and then i don't develop my king side
and then they always pop in with that
uh that g5 knight and then i'm like
crap i can't move my bishop out in front
i can't like
well the the really the olympics test
right
sorry continue no i was just gonna say i
just
i i just always feel like i get in this
weird spot
so i don't know it's it's a tough it's a
tough it's a tough uh
opening because it's always so so tricky
that's why it's withstood the test
of time it's been around for 500 years
another 10 my knockout oh my god thanks
man
damn girl so there's one key thing to
understand right like what makes the
move knight g5 dangerous
is precisely the fact that your dark
script bishop is not developed
if you're dark squared bishop and you
can look at my stream to look at the
position
if my dark squared bishop if you're an
artwork i'd been on you just castle
right
so that's literally the the reason why
you don't want to send white's bishop to
b3 prematurely
um yeah and for what it's worth the
actual norwegian variation goes knight
a5 mu5 you want to go after that bishop
as quickly as possible
interesting and um i was considering
going knight uh d4
but i wasn't sure if that was
i mean i felt like holy [ __ ] guys
amazing thank you that seemed like a
more central night you can trade off
your night if you want right
at this like whatever i dump my pawns i
guess but yeah
and and knight a5 this isn't a great
line because white explodes the center
with d4
and the theory goes on but at the very
least you don't have that bishop on b3
so there's a lot of like details here
but it's a very dubious line
so after knight f6 if i had gone knight
g5 on move
five what like which i didn't why did i
not do that like doesn't this just like
win the game
what do you have here this is an
important thing to remember in case you
get screwed like this you can at least
fight back a little bit
so i mean d4
yeah right d5 and if e takes d5 you have
a very important move
hint it's not knight takes people with
the knight
so are you familiar with the fried liver
yeah so in the fried liver um
and again i'll just make these moves on
my stream which is bishop c4
italian move three knight f6 knight g5
d5
e takes d5 that's the theory do you know
why black shouldn't take on d5
here what's the refutation
and this will help you understand that
position because it's literally just
like the same thing with some minor
modifications
if i if they do that then you take with
the knight there then the game takes
queen f3 is the check this is a famous
line black is basically losing
king e6 knight c3 and again there's a
lot of theory here but why does a
devastating attack this is like
a super you know like a well like one of
those traps that's
taught to every russian school boy kind
of thing so
the method of comparison i always play
bishop out first
right bishop c5 and that's what i highly
recommend by the way to everybody like
not to play knight f6 but to play bishop
c5
but for what it's worth against naichi
five takes
black has to know this move knight a5
like this is the main move that makes
black's position tenable
and literally because then it forces the
bishop off that line
yeah but basically this is a pawn
sacrifice line but why can give a bishop
b5 check
and black actually goes c6 this is a
hard line to understand if you've not
like
if you're not familiar with it because
black basically gives up a pawn and it's
not clear what he has in return for it
uh but why wouldn't i just take back
with the knight there
yeah so the the reason you don't take
back with a knight
it's not that this move is inherently
bad it's just that taking back with the
pawn gives black an initiative because
you attacked the bishop you have to play
with tempo here if you take with the
knight
white will complete his development by
castling or going sorry or going d3
gotcha so yeah actually d3 i think is
the key because watch what happens after
b takes c6 here
white has to drop the bishop back bishop
d3
and black goes h6 and chases the knight
away and if the knight goes back to f3
then what does black have here
exactly but now compare this to the
position after knight c6 white goes d3
and white is completely fine here black
has no initiative
so right the reason is you want to play
with tempo you have to play by attacking
white's pieces otherwise white
essentially consolidates
so if we were to transfer this now to
the the
text the the actual line in the game
knight f6 knight g5 d5 e takes d5 now it
should make sense why knight takes d5 is
bad here
right because it's the same idea it's
the same idea and
the modification actually is in white's
vapor if anything because the knight on
c6 that i'm highlighting with an arrow
is
uh is actually undefended so that adds
insult to injury right
uh but knight a5 here on the contrary is
even
is stronger than it is previously
because the bishop actually can't give
that check on b5
so does that make sense yeah
like you can't play bishop a4 it's just
gonna take
yeah and he has to trade his bishop off
no matter what which is very good for
black cause that's the main attacking
piece and the pawn on d5 is gonna lose
its support black's not even going to
give
you be upon down black's going to be
better probably
so that's why i played a preliminary
preliminary d4
to open up the center and tie down your
d-pawn and now i want knight g5
because if you go d5 here on move seven
this is a much
inferior version i can play d takes e5
and rip open the center
oh my god alicia thank you so much for
the ring i'm so sorry i missed alicia's
right
thank you so much i'll thank you
properly later thank you i really
appreciate it
i'm sorry i felt like d5 would have
still been fine
yeah you're gonna take and then i take
you know uh with my knight and then i
don't know it just feels like
now i'm defending
yeah i mean maybe here either i would
have either played
that swearing yeah so i would have
played e takes d5 and basically said
okay i'm up a pawn and i've got the
center pretty open
but this would be the lesser evil i
think the way you play it is very
ingenious this idea exists in many
different lines the problem is this
bishop takes f7 move without it i think
black is fine
so and after bishop f7 you're in huge
trouble like once i get that pawn out
get your king out into the center
you're you're in trouble so i actually
do think d5 is the last chance to get a
tenable position
yeah because i think i go d5 you take d5
i take d5 well then i have knight f75
yeah sorry you take e5 right i mean by
the way if
i do take d5 what do you do here like
which what what is black have in this
position
i'd probably do the same thing where i
go after you i'd imagine with the
a5 knight well now you have knight takes
d4 same exact idea just like you can
take the pawn
right oh yeah i guess i could just go
right in front of it yeah so but this is
all you're you're right in in spirit so
i play
d takes e5 as you said knight takes c5
and here like white
needs to decide white needs to
prioritize like i can either take your
pawn on d5 or i can just castle and
basically say
all right you take my pawn on e4 which
opens up my bishop not sure what's going
on there it's a pretty messy position
white's having all the fun that's for
sure but okay black is probably fine if
you're careful
yeah and i mean no no i feel okay in
this position here because like i
probably just play h6 kick your knight
away
you know even if you take or whatever
and then like
you know i can then develop and get to
more safety
so i was thinking of that d5 move and
then i just thought oh it'd be so cute
to play the bishop to g4
and it was it was cute and then and then
you took with your bishop and
then it wasn't quite it wasn't quite as
key yeah and after f3
i think really your last chance after
bishop h5 i just think it's completely
lost because i get that knight to e6
you know the funny thing is and this is
something that is hard to see
unless you look at the position the
right way that bishop on f7
you see it's it looks like it's a piece
you want to get rid of but it's actually
an asset for you
and i call this a type 2 undefended
piece right it's a piece that's defended
by only one other piece which is the
knight on g5
and potentially how can you get rid of
the knight on g5
what's the simple way of doing h6 right
so where can you put your bishop
so that it doesn't actually interfere
and give my bishop uh
a bailout option it's like an
anti-climactic
b7 yeah we're to ca right
d7 c8 so you're making white work for it
here like white is still much much
better probably winning i i would still
go d5
but you can like try h6 here you can try
to like mix things up and just
as a general piece of advice if you're
screwed like this
that's what you want to try to do you
want to try to confuse your opponent and
add some spice to the position because
when you play bishop h5
right you make my job very easy you give
me a chance to take on h5 and now i'm no
longer in any kind of danger
so as unpleasant as it is to play a move
like bishop d7 uh
you need to try to lull your opponent
into this false sense of confidence and
very he might miss h6 and then all of a
sudden black is black is winning
so okay after bishop
that's something that i found oh yeah
you know go ahead guys
i was gonna say that's something that
i've really found at this level
especially
um you know i'm sure it doesn't work at
your level as much but
uh i found that like before i used to
just
trade everything away you know i'd be
down like a piece or down a couple ponds
or a pond or whatever and i would just
kind of like trade stuff off and
simplify
and like pray that i could win the end
game um
sort of thing that they'd blunder there
but recently i started
uh just making crap super complicated
just creating like the weirdest
complications ever and then sure enough
they just like blunder a rook or
whatever
and it just it works super well because
we're just not good enough at our level
to see everything
and neither are gm's like that's also a
strategy on my level at like
at my level of complexity but the other
thing that that's associated with this
uh not to like beat a dead horse here
that bishop on f7 but that bishop is
like the source of a couple pieces of
advice
people think that when you there's a
piece that's in your territory
you automatically need to get rid of
that get it out right and sometimes
that's true like when i had
my knight on e6 i like what you tried to
do like uh
you tried to undermine it with c6 the
problem is it was too late
the knight was already too ensconced on
e6 but
there are sometimes my level would
totally take that pawn
right and give up the night and that's
why i liked what you did there i think
the spirit of what you did was great
but the thing is like the dividing line
if a piece is defended by a pawn that's
an outpost and that's a nasty piece
if a piece is not defended by a pawn
such as the bishop on f7
you can actually use a piece that's in
your territory to your advantage it
doesn't automatically make it good
just because it's sitting on you know f7
so that's something you should be
careful about
and you can again lure your opponent
into thinking that and not moving the
bishop out if that makes sense
yeah no i mean it makes a lot of sense
actually where it's just
yeah yeah i mean it's what i've just you
know from the like little
train you know a couple lessons i've
gotten or i've i've watched people you
know
it's always like if there's a aggressive
piece in your territory
kick it out of your territory that's
like always like the focus is like get
rid of it make it right
and you know so i've never really
thought of it as like an asset to myself
where it's like yeah i can just like
slip around and then suddenly push h6
and now they're in trouble right
right exactly so you know you wanna you
wanna catch your opponent on like
assumptions that he's making
uh from a general perspective and did
everything i make
did everything i did in this in the sort
of last part of the game did that all
make sense
uh it was there anything you wanted to
sort of talk through
you know from move 14 onwards
uh let me yeah refresh your memory on
the stuff that happens
um yeah that all seemed fine and made
sense
and it was just dismantling well i mean
the position at some point kind of
played i mean knight takes f8 was the
key move right
uh just transforming the advantage
because your knight on h5 is hanging
and so i'm moving my knight out with
tempo
so you know you did everything you could
i think the position was just
beyond salvation unfortunately it was
completely lost
when i didn't play d5 that was like
pretty much the end of that yeah yeah
like be
so so that's the key takeaway right
knight f6 on move four
and if you forget the memory marker you
can put in place is
king side development before b5 b4 b5 is
kind of a funny
mnemonic right you don't play b5 unless
you're ready to castle like that
you can distill that down to that
specific advice you should be a lot more
afraid
of the bishop on b3 than you should be
of me taking the knight on c6
um if that makes sense so
and having that bishop to bore line is
is helpful as well just for like what is
it what to do there in that case
there is one last exception
go ahead i was just going to say is
there a time because
i'm always scared to take on e4 yeah
sometimes they leave them on hanging and
then i always end up in some
my king is pinned situation right yeah
so right there so the thing is is is a
knight takes c4 is called the open road
that is actually a very legitimate move
but it's it's one of those things where
you get behind the wheel of like
a as i always say a bus and like you
gotta know how to drive the bus or
you're gonna crash it into the first
pole
so this is a very legitimate line it's
one of the best lines for black
but white has a variety of ways to test
black he goes d4 and opens up the e file
here you're not supposed to take that's
probably what you were implying like you
get pinned like this
so here you have to go b5 and then d5
and this has all of its theory i don't
recommend this to
people below like 2 000 because it
requires like
filigree precision for black to like not
lose in the first 10 moves
and so so you want to be careful about
that pawn on e4
the way that you want to do this is
again if you're ready to castle
then you can consider and they still
leave the e4 pawn hanging
uh like if you have a bishop on e7 and
let's say they play like c3
right instead of rookie one then you're
ready to castle so you can take on e4
and if they go rookie one you can just
say okay i'm gonna drop my knight back
they recapture the pawn but now you
castle you've got the lead in
development and white really hasn't
accomplished anything you just traded
the e-puns which is totally fine for you
yep so that's that would be worth it
there to
take their knight with your knight first
yeah that would be actually probably
even a better idea get the rook to a
vulnerable square then castle because
now you can play d6 with tempo and get
your bishop out quickly like white is
fighting for equality now
uh so also you can play b5 and then
fianco the bishop that's another good
idea
like now finally you can't play b5 if
you're not traumatized by that move
so that's uh but there was one last
thing
before i i'll let you sleep but uh just
one last
remark which is important uh you're
seeing my stream and i just played move
six
d3 so actually let me play it so whoops
i did not mean to do that
um so knight f6 actually move 5 d3
there is one exception to the rule
because here if you play bishop e7
that blunders upon do you see what is
the purpose of d3 what does white do
here
uh they can take the knight
and then take the pawn right and queen
d4 loses its effectiveness because the
e4 pawn is no longer hanging
so in this position actually
you want to play b5 here and you want to
play b5 and follow it up with what move
like the golden rule of b5 what do you
follow up with
uh play knight to a5
possible but again they'll be they'll
take the pawn on e5
so like what is the priority is always
king side development
now get my bishop yup not d6 because of
knight g5 is annoying uh but bishop
that's possible also but bishop e7 is
like the way i'd like you to play it and
then you castle
and then you play d6 at the end so d6 is
the least important of all of the moves
the most important is the king side
development followed by b5
when uh they are beginning to threaten
to capture your knight
sorry to overload you with all that if
they're they're then there you'll
definitely get the hang of it after a
couple games and i'm like happy to do
another session once you get a little
experience
that makes a lot of sense and that like
i completely understand that
and you honestly just went through like
all the different ways that i've
experimented with this and then i keep i
kept like
blundering it and i was like i have no
clue what to do because i'd go like e7
and then they would take the knight i'd
recapture and then they'd take the
stupid e pawn and i'm like
all right so i'm not supposed to do that
so then but then they made you with
knight g5
yeah they started playing d6 and they
start doing this knight g5 thing and i'm
like
there's no wind with this line i need to
study it obviously but i just never like
studied the opening on
it and uh yeah this one's always driven
me crazy
no the rye lopez is probably the most in
terms of like conceptual
understanding it's it's it's the most
annoying line because you have to
understand so much to be able to play
the other lines are just like a couple
traps you have to avoid
but i think now you'll get the hang of
it like give it one two games uh
like if you want like you can write down
the set of priorities right like first
king side development
then you play b5 only when they're
threatening to take your knight
and then d6 should usually like come
last or it should come right before you
castle
right so that basically is is the bottom
line
and yeah nothing like experience to like
cement that in your mind i think
yeah so but in any case that was that
was awesome
uh and and i really enjoyed that game
you did everything you could defensively
so keep your head up in that in that
sense
i tried uh hopefully next time
i'll defend better through the initial
opening and then can try and have a
better
middle mid game there absolutely and
you'll you'll get white next time
i'm happy to repeat this uh in the next
couple days i'll i'll uh we'll set
something up
more formally but uh this was awesome
thank you so much alex i appreciate you
staying up and
uh always love you in the stream you're
the best
so thanks for the game all right have a
great
day so much have a great night man bye
catch you later good night
all right well that was alex thanks alex
i appreciate it
and uh always love your support on the
stream and
uh that was a really fun game so that
was a little rai lopez course now a lot
of people are saying
that's why i play the sithilian but
here's the thing guys
you know they say there's nothing
nothing free in the world well the
sicilian is one of those things where
you think
let me just avoid all those problems
well guess what the sicilian has its own
set of problems and in particular
uh the allopin is annoying you know the
open sicilian
whatever you play is super theoretical
so um you know you can get crushed in
the situation and i have have gotten
crushed in like many different ways in
this italian
so i i love the sicilian i played it for
most of my life but it has its own
set of things that you have to know and
the smith mora i mean although you can
skirt it by
by going knight f6 uh and transposing
into the alpine by the way
so you don't actually need to accept the
smith mora but you know
it has its own set of problems and
that's what i really really want to
emphasize
[Music]
you